what is a polygon
many people define it as a closed figure
which has more than four sides
something like this
it's called a pentagon since it has five
sides
or maybe a six-sided figure which is
called a hexagon
or maybe even an eight-sided figure
which is an octagon
what about a three-sided figure a
triangle
or a four-sided figure a quadrilateral
are these two shapes called polygons
yes these two shapes are also called
polygons
which would mean this definition is
wrong
this is the definition of a polygon
it's a simple closed figure formed by
line segments which are in the same
plane
all the segments that form the figure
have to be on the same plane
these are the only conditions
the figure has to be closed and formed
by segments in the same plane
the number of sides may be 3 4 or 5 or
maybe even 100 it will still be a
polygon
but what is a regular polygon
we will see that next